[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليلى الاختيار اسهلها بابرز
العرب
تقرير صادم يكشف عدد الرؤوس النوويه
الجاهزه للاستخدام في العالم اكثر من 9000
بعد تصعيد
الاخير يحذر وزرائه ويشدد على العلاقه مع
واشنطن
بايدن يعترف باستمرار ازمه البنوك في
الولايات المتحده وانخفاض شعبيته لابنى
مستوياتها
الموظفون الحكوميون في امريكا
يودعون تيك توك او يودعون تيك توك بعد
انتهاء مهله الحكومه لحذف التطبيق
[موسيقى]
مع تواصل تلويح روسيا باسلحتها النوويه
التكتيكيه منذ بدايه الازمه الاوكرانيه
صدمه النوويه عالميه كشف عنها تقرير حديث
بارقام ضخمه نطلعها معكم مشاهدينا في
التاسعه هذا المساء
[موسيقى]
الترسانه العالميه النوويه المتاحه
للاستخدام ارتفعت الى اعلى المستويات منذ
الحرب البارده وفق ما كشف تقرير صادر عن
مرصد حظر الاسلحه النوويه واكد التقرير ان
الدول النوويه تسع كانت تمتلك 12 الفا
و512 راسا نوويا مطلق عام 2023 منها
2936 راسا محالا الى تقاعد وتسعه الاف
وخمسمائه وسته وسبعين راسا جاهز للاستخدام
من قبل الجيوش وهذا يعادل قوه تدميريه
بمقدار
135 الف قنبله كتلك التي سقطت على
هيروشيما اليابانيه وقال مدير مشروع
المعلومات النوويه ان المخزون النووي زاد
خلال الاشهر القليله الماضيه بمقدار 136
راسا نوويا مدفوعا بمواصله روسيا والصين
والهند وكوريا الشماليه وباكستان توسيع
مخزونها النوويه
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من واشنطن الجنرال
ماركه مساعد وزير الخارجيه الاسبق للشؤون
السياسيه والعسكريه جنرال يعني عندما
نتحدث عن سباق التسلح النووي الذي بدا بعد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه الى حين يعني
انتهاء وانهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي اليوم
نحن نتحدث عن مرحله جديده من هذا السباق
ماذا يعني بالنسبه للعالم
اود ان احدد اطار هذا الحديث من المهم ان
ندركه بان عدد الرؤوس النوويه ازداد بشكل
كبير جدا بالحرب البارده مثلا عام 1985
كانت هنالك خمسه اضعاف رؤوس الاناويه
مقارنه
بعدد ما بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه هناك
60 الف راس سنوي في ذلك الوقت وكلها كانت
تستهدف ليس فقط الاهداف العسكريه بل حتى
المراكز السكانيه والبنى التحتيه ومراكز
الاتصال الاساسيه الارقام الان مخيفه ليست
جيدا ولا تزال لديها القدرات على تدمير
اغلب الحياه على الارض ولكن المهم ان ركب
هذه الارقام هي عشر الى 15% مقاتله وكانت
عليه قبل حوالي 40 عاما من الان
جنرال يعني اليوم من المعلوم بان بوتين
اطلق يعني سباق التسلح النووي للمره
الاولى منذ الحرب البارده ومنذ انتهاء
الحرب البارده ونحن نتحدث عن مؤشرات
وارقام بزياده يعني زياده مقلقه للرؤوس
اللي هي التي هي جاهزه للاستخدام ماذا
يعني ذلك على الصراع المستقبل بين الدول
الكبرى
من المهمه ان ندرك بان كلا الدولتين
روسيا والولايات المتحده
تعشوا في مفهوم الضمان الدمار المشترك اي
اننا لن نسمح
لعدد من الاسلحه النوويه التي تضمن
قدره جانب او الاخر على ان ينتصر في اي
حرب
اي انه
نظريه ومبدا الضمان
الدمار المشترك اي ان اي جانب اذا ما اطلق
هجوم نووي سيكون للطرف الاخر القدره على
تدمين حضارات الدوله الاخرى
ولكن هذا المبدا
موجوده بين كافه الاتفاقات النوويه
الموقعه بين الدول وكذلك معاهده عدم
الانتشار الموقع من قبل اغلب الدول
لكن ما يقلقني عندما تقوم دول مثل روسيا
بالابتعاد عن مثل هذه المفاوضات ومثل هذه
البروتوكولات
ولكنني لا اصدق بان مخاطر
استخدامي الاسلحه النوويه ولا ليست هي
الان اعلم ما كانت عليه قبل خمسه اعوام
جنرال يعني بالمرحله الماضيه كنا نتحدث عن
عن مرحله نزع السلاح النووي في العالم
والذهاب نحو السلام الشامل حتى وان كان
يعني هو موجود عند القوى العالميه
الاساسيه اليوم نتحدث عن تعزيز السلاح
النووي بالترسانه العسكريه واستراتيجيه
للدول وهناك دول جديده ستنضم يعني الى
نادي الدول النوويه ماذا يعني ذلك ايضا
على مستقبل الصراع بين دول العالم
بالتاكيد هذا لا يدور بالمنفعه على السلام
او الاستقرار كلما زادت اي دوله من
مخزونها النووي ولكن الزيادات التي تنشدها
ارقامها قليله دعني اعطيك تاريخا مختلفا
تخيلي لو لم
نقم بالخفض الكبيره في الاسلحه النوويه
مطلع التسعينات ومطلع الالفينات هذه
الاتفاقات ولو لم تتوقعوا تصل اليها
اوكرانيا لكن لا يزال لديها ارساله كبيره
من الاسلحه النوويه البعض ربما يقول هذا
سيكون رادعا ولمنع روسيا من معالجه
اوكرانيا
اوكرانيا هوجمت واوكرانيا تزال لديها
استحناويه اعتقد باننا كنا سنشهد اسوا
سيناريو ممكن ولكن مره اخرى اقول بان الحل
الامثل لهذه الارقام المتزايده من الرؤوس
النوويه
تعني بان دول العالم والامم المتحده يجب
ان تدفع تجاه
القدرات
اتفاقات نوويه يمكن التحقق منها وتطبيقها
لتضمن عدم استخدامها
الروسي يحدد دائما بالانسحاب وهو طبعا
هناك اتفاقيه واحده اليوم تربطه مع الجانب
الامريكي وحتى هذه الاتفاقيه هي مهدده لان
يعني لان تزول بين الطرفين بسبب تحديد
الروسي دائما باستخدام النووي منذ بدء
الحرب بين الروس والاكرام التهديد
باستخدام النووي هل تاخذونه على محمل الجد
حتى وان كان هناك قناعه بان الحرب النوويه
يعني لا يربح فيها ولا اي طرف
وكما قلت لا يوجد اي منتصر في اي حرب
نوويه بين اي بلدين تمتلكان مخزون كبيرا
من الاسماويه ولكن السؤال هو اذا ما كانت
الولايات المتحده ستستجيب الاستخدام
الاسحاويه التكتيكيه داخل اوكرانيا
سياستنا حاليا هي ان نترك هذا الخيار
متاحا وغامضا
وغير معروف
فهذا يضيف بعض الغموض الى الحسابات
المستخدمه وحسابات رئيس بوتين لكي يقرر
عدم استخدام الصحه النوويه التكتيكيه هذا
الغموض مهم جدا
للتعبير لكلا البلدين حول كيف ستكون
الاستجابه او ربما لا تكن شكرا لك
مساعد وزير الخارجيه الاسبق للشؤون
العسكريه والسياسيه حدثنا من واشنطن
قامت القوات الصاروخيه الاستراتيجيه
التابعه للجيش الروسي بمناورات في سيبيريا
وذلك للسعرات قوتها النوويه الهائله
فلنتابع
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اطلقت مناوره
استراتيجيه في سيبيريا
المناورات تتضمن نشر صواريخ يارس
الاستراتيجيه في ثلاث مناطق شرقيه سيبيريا
صاروخ يارس العابد للقارات يصل مداه الى
12 الف كيلو متر
اي يستطيع ان يطال اوروبا وامريكا
الشماليه
سرعته القصوى 24 الف كيلو متر في الساعه
يحمل كل صاروخ من ثلاثه الى سته رؤوس
نوويه
بطاقه تدميريه تصل الى 500 كيلو طن
تمتلك روسيا
136 صاروخا على منصات متحركه
وسته عشره من منصات الاطلاق تحت الارض
[موسيقى]
نشروا السلاح النوويه التكتيكيه الروسيه
في الاراضي البيلاروسيه يثير قلق القوى
الغربيه وواشن تصفه بالخطير ما هي هذه
الاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه التي اربكت
الغرب لهذه الدرجه من بين تلك الاسلحه
مشاهدينا صواريخ جويه مزوده برؤوس نوويه
ستحملها 10 طائرات تابعه لسلاح الجو
البيلاروسي وسيتم تجهيز تلك الطائرات
لتكون قادره على حمل رؤوس اسلحه نوويه
يبلغ مداها 2500 كيلومتر وفقا طبعا
للاعلام الروسيه الاسلحه تشمل ايضا منصات
منظومه اسكندر العملاتيه تكتيكيه التي
يمكن ان تصيب صواريخها اهدافا تبعد مسافه
2500 كم ايضا وباستطاعه الراس القتلي الذي
يحمله صاروخ اسكندر ان يحدث انفجارا بقوه
50 كيلو طنا اي ما يزيد بمقدار عن نح
ثلاثه اضعاف عن قوه القنبله التي تم
اسقاطها عام 1945 على هيروشيما اليابانيه
اما السلاح النووي الاستراتيجي الروسي هنا
طبعا فيكمن ويمكن ان تنشرهم ايضا بموافقه
بيلاروسيا لانها لا يزال فيها اكثر من
ثمانين منصه ثابته تحت الارض صواريخ
الباليستيه العابره للقارات في حاله تقنيه
جيده ويمكن هنا لروسيا ان تضرب بسلاحها
التكتيكي اي نقطه في اي دوله تابعه في
اوروبا في حال طبعا تعرضها او حلفتها
بيلاروسيا لاي هجوم محتمل خلال هذه الحرب
[موسيقى]
ازمه حل التعديلات القضائيه تفتح سجالا
حادا وعلنيا هو الاول من نوعه في تاريخ
العلاقات بين الولايات المتحده واسرائيل
بعدما وجهت اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن رساله شديده اللهجه للحكومه
الاسرائيليه حذرت فيها من ان اسرائيل لا
يمكنها مواصله مسار المواجهه القضائيه
داعيه طبعا رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتانياهو للتوصل الى تسويه حقيقيه
واشنطن رفعت البطاقه الحمراء بوجه نتنياهو
بعدما قالها بايدن صراحه انه يعتزم عدم
دعوه نتنياهو الى البيت الابيض في المدى
القريب الامر الذي رد عليه الاخير معتبرا
ان اسرائيل دوله مستقله تتخذ قراراتها من
دون اي ضغوط خارجيه صحيفه اسرائيليه كانت
نقلت عن وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
التمار بتغفير قوله ان على الولايات
المتحده ان تدرك ان اسرائيل ليست نجمه في
العالم الامريكي وبالتالي هي دوله مستقله
وليست ولايه امريكيه
[موسيقى]
وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه افادت بان الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن وجهها رساله قاسيه
لرئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
بعد اقالاته وزير الدفاع
واوضحت المصادر الاسرائيليه ان بايدن طالب
نتنياهو بالتراجع فورا عن تعديلات القضاء
في رساله نقلها السفير الامريكي التي كانت
شخصيه وسريه وهدد الرئيس الامريكي رئيس
وزراء اسرائيل بالاستبعاد من قمه
الديمقراطيه اذا لم يتم وقف التعديلات
القضائيه في السياق اكد مسؤول اسرائيلي ان
نتنياهو يريد تجنب ازمه مع بايدن ويريد
وضع ازمه القضاء خلفه
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من القدس شولومو
جانور المحلل السياسي للحديث اكثر عن هذا
الموضوع استاذ يعني اليوم المقاطعه او
التانيب على المستوى السياسي والمستوى
القيادي هي طبعا ليست على المستوى
والاستراتيجي بالعلاقات بين الولايات
المتحده واسرائيل هل تتخوفون في حال يعني
اقدم نتنياهو مجددا على التحدي بموضوع
التعديلات القضائيه من ان تتطور اكثر
اعتقد بان تاشيرات وتلميحات وتهديدات
واقوال الرئيس الامريكي الواضحه
استمعت اليها الجهات الاسرائيليه
الاسرائيليه العليا وخدتها بعيد الاعتبار
حيث انها فوجئت من شده هذه اللهجه وايضا
من التعبير الذي لقي نفسه من اعلى
المستويات الامريكيه بصوره علنيه امام
عدسات التلفزيون وذلك بالرغبه من الاتيكيت
والتقاليد الدبلوماسيه المتبعه بالحفاظ
على
العلاقات او حتى على التعبير البؤسيه ولكن
انت تتم داخل الغرفه هنا المفاجاه لصالح
ولكن من جهه ثانيه هناك مساعي خفيفه من
قبل كلا الطرفين
لتخفيف حتى تتوتر التي بلغت اليوم واعتقد
بان في الطريق ايضا تليين في الموقف او في
لهجه
التعبير الامريكيه هذا المساء حيث يتوقع
ان تاتي توضيحات امريكيه من البيت الابيض
هذا الاتجاه لان اقوال الرئيسه بيتا مع كل
شدتها كانت ارتجاليه كانت مفاجئه بالنسبه
له ايضا ولم تكن مدروسه وهي جاءت تلقائيا
ربما للتعبير عن مشاعره الخاصه الحميمه
الصادق واتجاه اسرائيل ولكن للاسف الشديد
وقعت فيها بعض الاخطاء وهي يجب تسويه هذا
الخلاف استاذ شو الامور يعني من المعلوم
ايضا ان اللوبي اليهودي في الولايات
المتحده اليوم هو معارض لخطوات نتنياهو
وهو له يعني كلمه كبيره ومسموعه عند
الداخل الديمقراطي الى اي مدى استمد
الرئيس القوه من هذا اللوبي للضغط اكثر
على نتنياهو بموضوع التعديلات وموضوع يعني
الضغط علنا عليه
لا سرا هناك انشقاق داخل الصف اليهودي
الامريكي وتجاوبه مع
شخصيا وما حكومه اليمين المتشدده حاليا
زاد على ذلك بان هناك ايضا التباعد في
القياده الامريكيه اليهوديه عن اسرائيل
خاصه في الجيل الناشئ الامريكي اليهودي
ولهذا تعبيرا ايضا في اقوال او في مسانده
الموقف الامريكي الرسمي من قبل الجاليه
اليهوديه
الامريكيه ومن هنا
استمد الرئيس بايدن الكره او الشده
التعبيري استنادا الى هذا الانتقاد او
لهذا الاشمئزاز القائم او هذا التباعد
البرايم بين الجاليه اليهوديه الامريكيه
الناشئه وبين القياده الاسرائيليه الحاليه
عندما يعني تعتبر المنظمات والجمعيات
اليهوديه هناك اتحدث عن المنظمات الفاعله
بان مقام به نتنياهو يتعارض هو انقلاب غير
مسبوق وهجوم غير مسبوق على نظام الضوابط
والتوازنات الذي يتعارض بشكل مباشر مع
القيم المشتركه الامريكيه الاسرائيليه
ماذا يعني ذلك ايضا من ضغط خارجي على
نتانياهو بظل الضغط والانقسام الداخلي
الموجود
اعتقد ان استوعب الرسائل الموجه الي ليس
فقط من الحلبه الامريكيه بل ايضا من
الحرباء
من العواصم الاوروبيه المختلفه التي زارها
خلال الشهر الاخير ولذلك يحاول الان بكل
القوات الابداء المرونه ابداع اعاده
المواقف ومن هنا القرار الذي اتخذه بتجميد
مشروع الاصلاح الى الموافقه على الحوار
الوطني تحت مظله رئيس الدوله الى استعداده
الى شطف بعض المواضيع والمشاريع القوانين
التي تثير الجدل داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي
وخاصه داخل
الاحزاب المعارضه ولذلك شاهدنا خلال
اليومين الاخيرين خفه في المظاهرات التي
عمت اسرائيل خلال الاسبوع الاخير شكرا لك
استاذ شلومو غانو المح يا السياسي حدثنا
من القدس
[موسيقى]
بعد مرور نحو شهر من تعيينها افادت مصادر
لمجالات نيوزويك الامريكيه بان الكولونيل
الجنرال الروسي رستم مورادوف والذي اقيل
من منصبه كرئيس للمنطقه العسكريه الشرقيه
في اوكرانيا وكان القائد العسكري الخمسيني
مسؤولا عن قياده الهجوم في مدينه فوليدار
في منطقه دومباس لكن مصادر نيوز تقول انه
استبعد بعد فشل روسيا في الاستيلاء على
المدينه بعد معركه استمر ثلاثه اسابيع خسر
خسرت خلالها موسكو عشرات المركبات المدرعه
ورغم ان الكريم لم يؤكد نبا اقصائه الا ان
مجموعه فاجنر لطالما انتقدت ميرادوف لانه
فشل في اداء مهامه
من جانبه قال مؤسس مجموعه فاجنر ان عمليات
قواتي في محمود ادت الى هزيمه الجيش
الاوكراني ولكنها تسببت في اضرار كبيره
لقواته كما قال ايضا ان انتصار فاجنر في
بخموت سيقلب بشكل كبير العمليه الخاصه
راسا على
استمرار القتال في مدينه بخموت الواقعه
شرقيه اوكرانيا بين قوات روسيا واوكرانيا
وثق جندي اوكراني حجم الدمار في المدينه
قائلا ان المدينه تتعرض لقصف مستمر
بالالغام وانه لا يوجد احد في المدينه
فلنتابع لموثقه
تتعرض المدينه لقصف مستمر بالالغام عمليا
لا يوجد احد في الشارع الجميع اما في
مواقع او في ملاج اود ان اقول ان هذا
الجزء من المدينه يخضع لسيطره القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه ولا يمكن للعدو الوصول
الى
[موسيقى]
محامي ترامب يتبرا من تصريحاته حول دمار
الولايات المتحده اذا ما وجهت له تهم
جنائيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الازمه المصرفيه لم
تنتهي بعد يقول هنا الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن الذي تتراجع شعبيته الى ادنى مستوى
بسبب هذه الازمه فوفقا لاخر استطلاع للراي
نشرته شبكه
فوكس نيوز الامريكيه ارقام استطلاع اظهرت
تراجع نسبه تاييد بايدن في مارس الى 38
بالمئه بعدما كانت 43% في فبراير الماضي
بايدن اوضح انه يفعل كل ما هو ممكن
لمعالجه الازمه المصرفيه داعيا الكونجرس
الى فرض عقوبات اكثر صرامه على كبار
المسؤولين التنفيذيين في البنوك الذين
يساهمون بسوء ادارتهم في فشل مؤسساتهم في
اشارات طبعا الى الفوضى التي خلفها انهيار
بنكي سيليكون فالي وسجنتشر مؤخرا ما ادى
طبعا الى تراجع كبير في ثقه المستثمرين في
القطاع المصرفي الذي هوت اسهمه وثارت
مخاوف من حدوث ازمه ماليه شامله كما اسهمت
مشاهدينا ايضا صفقه انقاذ بنك
الاسبوع الماضي واعلان بنك فرصه انه
سيستحوذ على ودائع وقروض بنك سيليكون فالي
لاستعاده بعض الهدوء للاسواق لكن
المستثمرين طبعا ما زالوا قلقين من المزيد
من المشكلات الكامنه في النظام المالي
العالمي وفي وقت سابق اتهم البنك المركزي
الامريكي امام لجنه في مجلس الشيوخ انا
بنك سيليكون فالي اقدم على اجراءات بالغه
سوء فيما يتعلق باداره المخاطر قبل
انهياره
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من واشنطن عبر سكايب
طارق الشامل الكاتب والمحلل السياسي استاذ
طارق طبعا اداء الرئيس دائما ينعكس على
الحزب على استطلاعات الراي على النتائج
الانتخابيه ولكن المعلوم بان بالولايات
المتحده تحديدا هناك يعني وقت امامنا امام
الانتخابات وبالتالي لا شيء حاسم حتى
الساعه التحدي الاساسي اليوم موضوع المالي
موضوع اذا ما كان الاقتصاد الامريكي سيدخل
بمرحله ركود كيف يمكن للرئيس الامريكي ان
يتخطى هذه المرحله الحرجه السنه الماليه
الحرجه بالفتره المقبله
نعم الرئيس بايدن لا شك انه يواجه مشكله
كبيره في الاقتصاد وخاصه بالنسبه
لمعدلات التضخم لا شك ايضا ان المشكله
الماليه الاخيره التي جسدها بنك سيليكون
فالي وسجناتشر
والمخاوف ايضا التي ما زالت مستمره من ان
تكون هناك تداعيات ما زالت كامله في
الاسواق كل هذا يؤثر على ادائه وعلى
شعبيته اخر استطلاعات للرائي تقول بان
شعبياته ما زالت في حدود 38 بالمئه وهي
تقل بذلك عن المستوى الذي سجلته وهو 43
قبل يعني عده اسابيع هذا يعني ان شعبيته
تتراجع معدلات التضخم الاخيره في شهر
فبراير الماضي كانت ايضا مرتفعه هي زادت
سته يعني بوينت 6
في المئه وهذا يعني ان
التضخم ما زال مستمرا وهو ما يقلق كثير من
الامريكيين لان الاولويه في استطلاعات
الراي تشير الى ان الاولويه الاولى لدى
غالبيه الامريكيين يعني نحو 30% منهم هي
تتعلق بالاداء الاقتصادي في حين ان عشرين
بالمئه فقط
تتعلق بمساله الديمقراطيه وتعزيز
الديمقراطيه بالموضوع المالي تحديدا بايدن
كان ينتقد دائما ترامب بسبب تدخله
بالسياسات الماليه ومن المعلوم بان
السياسات السياسات النقديه عفوا هناك
تضارب دائما بين السياسات الماليه وسياسات
النقديه اليوم يعني تخفيض
التضخم لعدم الذهاب الى ركود هو الهم
الاساسي لبايدن اذا ما وصل الى نقطه وطبعا
يعني المؤشرات كلها تشير باننا ذاهبين الى
ركود اذا ما وصل الى هذه النقطه هل ممكن
ان يحصل تضارب على المستوى المالي والنقدي
بينه وبين المركز هناك
يعني المجلس الاحتياطي الفيدرالي وهو
البنك المركزي هو مستقل هذا من المفترض ان
يكون مستقلا عن اداء
الاداره وبالتالي هناك
رهانات على ان يضل المجلس الاحتياطي
الفيدرالي يوازن بين فكره كبح جماح التضخم
من خلال التهدئه في عمليه رفع سعر الفائده
لاحظنا انه في المره الاخيره وبسبب
تداعيات بنك سيليكون فالي هو رفع سعر
الفائده ربع نقطه فقط وهذا يعني انه كان
حريصا على ان يضر بعمليه
الاستقرار المالي في البنوك والمصارف وفي
نفس الوقت يحاول ان يعطي اشاره بانه مستمر
في سياسته النقديه الخاصه بكبح التضخم من
خلال رفع سعر الفائده لكن هل هو سوف
يستطيع الاستمرار في ذلك هذا يتوقف على ما
هي التداعيات التي ما زالت يمكن ان تحصل
فيما يتعلق بالاستقرار المالي
البنوك هناك
يعني ملف البنوك لم ينتهي بعد ولا نعلم
يعني الى اين الى اين
متى سيتوقف اليوم يعني القاء اللوم على
الرئيس بسبب ما حصل هو اليس هو مبالغ
طالما هناك فصل في الولايات المتحده بين
الحكومه وجهات الرقابيه ام ان الموضوع فقط
بانه بان يعني لم يروا الازمه اتيه مع ان
الاجراءات التي اخذوها كان هناك رضا عنها
نعم لا شك انه هناك فعلا كثير من الماخذ
لانه في الجلسات التي تجرى الان في مجلس
النواب هناك جلسات استماع تجرى
لاعضاء في المجلس الاحتياطي الفيدرالي
وكذلك مسؤولون في وزاره الخزانه وفي
الهيئه الفيدراليه الخاصه بالتامين على
الودائع كل هؤلاء يتعرضون الان لتحقيقات
يعني استجوابات شديده لانهم فشلوا في
معرفه او في اطلاق انذار
للسلطات المختلفه في البلاد بان هناك
مشكله وانهم لم يفعلوا ما كان يجب ان
يفعلوه خصوصا وان الاتهامات كلها تتعلق
بسوء اداره بنك سيليكون فالي وهو حتى
اعضاء الكونجرس تحدثوا على انهم هم علموا
فقط في يوم العاشر من مارس بالازمه ولم
يحصلوا على اي التحديثات او معلومات
اضافيه من مجلس الاحتياط الفيدرالي هناك
بالفعل استجوابات الرئيس
تصرف في حدود
صلاحياته وهي محدوده هي ليست واسعه النطاق
هناك اتهامات متبادله طبعا من الاداره
تتهم
الكونجرس السابق في انه في عهد الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب انهم خففوا من
الاجراءات التقليديه على البنوك وما زالت
هذه النقطه حتى الان ما زالت مسار خلاف
ليس فقط بين الجمهورين والديمقراطيين بل
ايضا هناك انقسام داخل الديمقراطيين فيما
يتعلق بهذه النقطه لان هناك مخاوف من ان
يؤدي مزيد من التقييد على البنوك المتوسطه
الحجم التي تتراوح اصولها بين 100 مليار
الى 250 مليار انها سوف يؤثر على
نمو الاقتصادي في البلاد وبالتالي هناك
انقسام ولهذا لا يعتقد بان اداره بايدن
سوف تقوم بطرح هذه الافكار بقوه فكره ان
يكون هناك تقييد او العوده الى النظام
السابق من حيث تقييد الاجراءات هناك
اجراءات سوف تتخذ تطرحها يطرحها يعني بكل
الاحوال
هو انا ماليه يعني حذره وحرجه على مستقبل
الحزب ومستقبل السياسي شكرا لك استاذ طارق
الشامي الكاتب والمحل السياسي حدثنا من
الولايات المتحده من واشنطن تحديدا
[موسيقى]
دون ان يكشف عن طبيعته كشف رئيس هيئه
الاركان الامريكيه عن سباق تصلح مع الصين
الذي قال انها تخطط للسيطره على غربيه
الهادئ في غضون 15 سنه لكن يبدو ان
ذهبت الى ابعد من ذلك فلنتابعه
هناك سباق تسلح غربي المحيط الهادئ نراقب
الوضع عن كثب الصين تخطط للهيمنه على غرب
المحيط الهادئ خلال عشرين الى خمسه عشره
سنه تصريح يشري بحجم التنافس في المياه
الهادئه هنا وبالنظر الى غرب المحيط
الهادئ فالمنطقه المقصوده تطول لتشمل بحري
الصين الشرقي والجنوبي وتتجاوز تايوان
بؤره الصراع مع واشنطن وصولا الى جزر
سليمان في اقصى الجنوب الى الشرق من
استراليا الجزر التي جمعتها بالصين العمل
الفائت اتفاقيه امنيه اثارت حفيظه
الجيراني وغيرهم ومن خلال ما تعلنه واشنطن
وان لم تنفي او تؤكد لكنها تصرح بقدر ما
هو يستوجب الرد منها وكان تعدى الامر بها
غربي الهادئ الى اقصى شرقه حيث الهندوراس
بلد قطع علاقته مع تايوان واعلنها صراحه
نلتزم بصين واحده الصين وان لم تفصح
الولايات المتحده عن طبيعه السباق في
التسلح تضرب عرض الحائط بردود فعل واشنطن
وما تصفها بالادعاءات الامريكيه ادعاءات
كان اخرها اجبرت هندوراس على قطع علاقتها
بتايوان علقت عليها المتحدثه باسم
الخارجيه الصينيه
بمثل صيني
يمر القارب بالاف الجبال وصراخ القرده
مستمر بلا نهايه
قال محامي ترامب فان منشورات الرئيس
الامريكي السابق ضد محامي منطقه منعاه
الذي يحقق معه في جرائم ماليه محتمله غير
حكيمه لكنه اشار الى ان ترامب نفسه لم
ينشرها المزيد مشاهدينا في التقرير التالي
انا لست مستشارا في وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي بهذه الجمله اخلى محامي الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب مسؤوليته عن
اي منشورات لترامب فهل تخلى اقرب موظفي
الرئيس الامريكي عنه
يعرف عن ترامب احبه وعشقه لمواقع التواصل
التي لطالما استخدمها لايصال رسائله
الخاصه لخصومه اخرها وجهت لشخص لم يكن
خصما ولا منافسا هو مدعي عاما هاتا الفن
براك المسؤول عن التحقيق في قضايا جنائيه
ماليه تلاحق ترامب اثناء حملته الانتخابيه
عام 2016 قبل ايام صعد الرئيس الامريكي
السابق من لهجته واشار في منشور الله عبر
منصته للتواصل
الى موت ودمار محتملين اذا تم توجيه
الاتهام اليه في القضيه
سبقتها جمله من ردات الفعل للرئيس
الامريكي السابق عبر سلسله تغريدات له
اثار بعضها حفيظه مناصريه ودفعت اخرين
للتحذير من تداعياتها تحدث فيها ترامب عن
مزاعم اعتقاله
هنا نعود للسؤال عن تفسير تصريحات ابرز
شخص حاليا في قضيه ترامب الجنائيه محاميه
والمدافع عنه
انتقد منشورات الرئيس الامريكي السابق على
الانترنت ضد مدعي منطقه
ووصفها بغير الحكيمه لكنه في الوقت نفسه
لم يتخلى عن موكله تماما بل اشار الى ان
ترامب لم ينشر تلك التهديدات بنفسه
اعتقد ان هذا كان منشورا غير حكيم وضعه
احد العاملين على وسائل التواصل وسرعان ما
حذفه عندما ادرك الخطاب والصوره المرفقه
به صرح ترامب ام لم يصرح ودين ام لم يدنو
اذا كان هناك شيء واحد اصبح واضحا بشكل
متزايد بشان مستقبل ترامب الرئاسي لعام
2024 فهو ان هذه الحمله ستكون اكثر شراسه
من سابقتها
روان حمزه العربيه
[موسيقى]
رئيس الفرنسي مانيويل مصر على اللاقات
الثلاث لا للتراجع عن قانون نظام التقاعد
لا لتعديل وزري ولا لحل مجلس النواب ورغم
الحراك الاحتجاجيه الذي شارك فيه اكثر من
مليون شخص وفقه وزاره الداخليه ولكن
انضمام الشباب وطلاب الى الحراك اعطى نفحه
جديده للتظاهرات واظهر عمق الازمه
الداخليه التي تواجه ماكرون بعدما قرر
طلاب اغلاق المدارس الثانويه الخاصه بهم
كما تقول هنا صحيفه الجارديون البريطانيه
التي اعتبرت ان الطلاب كانوا بعيدين في
المرحله الاولى من التظاهرات التي تقودها
النقابات العماليه واضرابات النقل ضد خطه
ماكرون لرفع سنه التقاعد الى 64 عاما الا
انهم تقدموا الى الساحه مؤخرا لانتزاع
حقوقهم الاجتماعيه من الحكومه وتحديدا بعد
استخدام العنف المفرط من قبل الشرطه
الفرنسيه بوجه مظاهرين وتعنت الحكومه في
قراراتها رغم الصرخه الشعبيه الكبيره ضد
هذه المطالب هنا قدرت الصحيفه البريطانيه
اعداد الطلاب باكثر من 90 الف طالب اي
ثلاثه اضعاف من حضروا الاسبوع الماضي هذا
المشهد سيقيد عمل الشرطه وسيرضعها طبعا عن
استخدام العنف المفرط ضد تلاميذ تتراوح
اعمارهم بين 17 عاما وثمانيه عشر عاما
المشهد الفرنسي مشاهدينا المطرب بسبب
الذعر وفق صحيفه نموض الفرنسيه قالت بان
البلد ينهار بعدما الغى الملك تشارلز
ديارته الى باريس معتبره ان هذا القرار
اضر بهيبه الدوله الفرنسيه فيما لا يزال
ماكرون مصرا على موقفهم والشرطه الفرنسيه
هنا تمارس العنف بشكل مفرط ضد المتظاهرين
والصور الاخيره كشفت هذا الامر فلنتابع
الصور
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من باريس
المحلل السياسي استاذه
ثمه شيء مشترك يعني في تاريخ الحركه
الطلابيه الشبابيه الفرنسيه
بالشارع في عام 68
73-18 كلها حركات نزلت اليها الشباب الى
الشارع وحولوا كل المطالب ان كانت سياسيه
اجتماعيه وغيرها الى امر واقع اليوم
باستخدام القوه والعنف المفرد ضد هؤلاء هل
يخدم سياسه الرئيس الفرنسي
مساء الخير اولا طبعا يعني تتحدثين عن
الشباب وهو معروف بان الطلاب بالاخص كل
الحركات الاحتجاجيه والحركات الفكريه
بالاساس هي تنمو تنشا وتنمو وتترعرع في
الجامعات وبين الطلاب وبالاخص السنويين
ولكن يعني الوضع يختلف الان عما كانت عليه
بالاخص ثوره 68 لانها كانت الثوره التحرر
من القيود من بناء مجتمع جديد وعن خروج عن
التقاليد مختلفه ولكن الاداه اتحدث عن
اداه الشباب التي تفرض هذه على على النظام
السياسي
ين حصلت تظاهرات وكانت هناك اعمال عنف
بالواقع كانت من قبل الشارع اكثر مما كانت
من السلطه حصل شلل عام في البلاد نوع من
الانتفاضه حتى لا نقول الثوره وكانت هناك
حتى بعض المدن مقطوعه عن باريس وبعض
الشوارع داخل العاصمه ضمن حواجز من قبل
المحتاجين الشرطه حتى الان لم تقم بعد اي
اعمال على الاقل من الناحيه القانونيه
ملامه عليها وانها تخرج عن اطار استخدام
ما هو متاح ضمن القوانين من اجل الحفاظ
على الامن العام القانون يتيح للناس
التظاهر وللتعبير عن ارائهم ضمن شروط
اهمها الحفاظ على الاستقرار والامن العام
اليوم المشكله الاساسيه هي الى اي حد يمكن
للمنظمين من جهه لان عليهم ايضا مسؤوليه
منظمه المتظاهرات والنقابات وكذلك بالنسبه
الحكوميه الى اي حد يستطيعون ضبط الشارع
وهذه الحركات ضمن ما هو متاح وما هو لا
يضر المصلحه العامه لان اي تجاوز اليوم قد
يؤدي الى وقوع جرحى او ربما الى وقوع
ضحايا والراي العام الفرنسي الذي يؤيد
الان بنسبه 63%
المتظاهرين او الطلاب او المطالب بالاحرى
مطالب
المتظاهرين قد ينقلب عليهم اذا ما تطورت
كل هذه التظاهرات الى اعمال شغب الى حرق
في الشوارع السيارات تكسير محال عمليات
نهب كما راينا مع السترات الصفر والتي
انتهت هذه الحركه سترات السفر بتاييد اقل
من 30% على ما اعتقد على ما اذكر بينما
انطلقت فوق الخمسين صحيح
63% من الفرنسيين يؤيدون هل سيبطون على
تاييدهم اذا ما طالت حركه الاحتجاجات تم
تعطيل الحياه العامه في البلاد النقل
الوظائف
الرسميه
اليوم اليوم ستكون هناك ضرر اقتصادي
واجتماعي
يتخطى الضرر الامني
هذا معلوم ضرر اقتصادي ضرر اجتماعي ضرر
على كل الصعد ولكن اليوم يعني افق الحل
مسدوده بسبب اصرار الرئيس الفرنسي على
تمرير هذا القانون واسرار الشارع موجود ما
الذي سيحصل يعني هذه التظاهرات ستبقى
والاحتجاج سيبقى كيف يمكن الحد يعني من ما
تتحدث عنه من تاثير العنف بالشارع
الجلسات مع الحكومه والحكومه بالمقابله
رئيس الحكومه ابدت ايضا مدت يد العون
بالقول بان ليس هناك جدول اعمال غير
متحركه يعني جدول اعمال خلال هذه اللقاءات
اليوم للخروج من هذه هو ايضا هو هو ايضا
التعويل على قرار مجلس الدستوري الذي
سيعطي قراره في 14 من الشهر المقبل هناك
ايضا بعض الكلام بدا يظهر عن امكان ان
يجري الرئيس تعديلا حكوميا يتضمن حتى ايضا
يشمل رئيسه الحكومه في حاله توصل الى
تنازلات متبادله من قبل الطرفين تؤدى الى
عنه بعد الصحف الفرنسيه بان يتم التضحيه
من جهه معينه وهي طبعا جهه حكوميه ستكون
بانتظار قرار المجلس الدستوري والتطورات
بالايام المقبله شكرا لك استاذ اندريم
هاوج المحلل السياسي حدثنا من باريس
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اصدر رئيس دوله الامارات
الشيخ محمد بن زايد قرارا بتعيين الشيخ
منصور بن زايد نائبا لرئيس الدوله الى
جانب الشيخ محمد بن راشد وقرر الشيخ محمد
بن زايد تعيين الشيخ خالد بن محمد بن زايد
وليا للعهد في اماره ابوظبي كما اصدر
الشيخ محمد بن زايد قرارا بتعيين الشيخ
هزاع بن زايد والشيخ طحنون بن زايد يبين
لحاكم ابو ظبي
[موسيقى]
ينتهي اليوم الموعد الاخير لموظفي
الوكالات الفيدراليه الامريكيه لازاله
التطبيق الصيني من الاجهزه وهو تيك توك من
الاجهزه الحكوميه طبعا بعد توجيهات من
البيت الابيض تقضي بحجبه عن هواتفهم وبررت
الاداره الامريكيه القرار بمخاوف تتعلق
بالامن والخصوصيه بشان الروابط المزعومه
لتطبيق وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي مع
الحكومه الصينيه
هبطت طائره الملك تشارلز الثالث وزوجته
كامله في برلين العاصمه الالمانيه التي
تستقبل العائله الملكيه في اول زياره دوله
يقوم بها الملك تشارلز الى الخارج منذ
اعتلائه عرش بريطانيا وستبقى العائله
المالكه في المانيا لثلاثه ايام للاحتفال
بعلاقه الصداقه بين البلدين وكان يفترض ان
يتوجه الملك وزوجته اولا الى فرنسا قبل
المانيا الا ان الزياره الغيت بسبب
الاحتجاجات المرتبطه بقانون التقاعد في
هذا البلد
[موسيقى]
خصصت الرئاسه العامه لشؤون المسجد الحرام
25 موظفي يعملون على قياس رضا المعتمرين
وكافه الخدمات المقدمه لهم من خلال 75 لوح
تمكن الزائرين من ابداء حول الخدمات
المقدمه لهم في المسجد الحرام وذلك لتحسين
منها
[موسيقى]
كبير وطاقه قصوى للمسجد الحرام في استقبال
مئات الالاف من المعتمرين والزوار يوميا
خلال شهر رمضان هذه الاعداد الكبيره تتطلب
تطويرا مستمرا للخدمات عبر قياسي رضاهم عن
الخدمات المقدمه تعمل اداره
تجربه معايير متبعه من مركز اداء الوطني
لقياس الجهات الحكوميه كذلك تعمل الاداره
على اربع ورديات مختلفه تقوم بقياس نسبه
الرضا وفق معايير معتمده من مركز اداء
الوطني لقياس الجهات الحكوميه ايقوم يقوم
الفريق الميداني في النزول على ارض الواقع
واخذ الانطباعات مباشره ورفع تقارير لحظيه
مسوحه احصائيه ميدانيه تجريها وكاله قياس
الاداء والجوده بالرئاسه العامه لشؤون
المسجد الحرام بشكل يومي حيث تستهدف
استطلاع اراء خمسه الاف معتمر ومصلي يقوم
المختصين لدى المركز بعمليه المقابله
الشخصيه مع المعتمرين
وسؤالهم عن المده المستغرقه في كل قسم من
هذه الاقسام الخاصه بالعمره سواء في
الطواف او في السعي او المده الانتقال بين
الطواف والسعي
وبعد ذلك يقوم مركز الحصان والمعلومات
باخذ متوسط مده المتوسط مده العمره
جاهزيته المصليات واعمال النظافه واداره
الحشود ابرز الخدمات التي يجري بحت رضا
المعتمرين عنها لتفادي اي اخطاء فيما تبقى
من شهر رمضان
واستعدادا للموسم الاكبر موسم حج هذا
العام من الحرم المكي سلطان السلمي
العربيه
ازمه الطفل شنوده التي
اثارت على مدى عام بعد فصله عن اسرته التي
تبنته وربت بعدما عثرت عليهم منذ خمس
سنوات في احدى الكنائس نظرا للصراع الذي
حدث حول ديانه الطفل قبل ان يحسم الازهر
الجدل بتبعيه الطفل للديانه المسيحيه
واعادته لوالديه بالتبني رنده ابو العزم
رافقت الاسره اثناء اجراءات تسلم الطفل
ورفضت لحظات الفرح فلنتابع هذا التقرير
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نهايه سعيده وبدايه لحياه سعيده للطفل
شنوده الذي عاد اخيرا الى حضن اسرته
بالتبني امال وفاروق بعد رحله معاناه
للطفل والاسره امتدت لاكثر من عام بقى لما
شوفتي شنوده النهارده عملتي ايه طبعا
حضنته وبصته وهو باسني وحضني وقال لي يا
ماما كفايه دي بالدنيا كلها تفتكري مدام
امال ان هو هيحتاج اي حد نفسي يقعد معه
يريحه بصي اكيد اكيد بس انا يعني الاول
الكنيسه وكده
وربنا يتدخل بقى ربنا يكمل نفسك تشوفي
شنوده فين بيشتغل ايه عايزه مستقبل حاطط
في مخه انه يطلع دكتور كان كل ما حد يساله
يقول له انا اسمي الدكتور شنوده فاروق
فوزي بولس غبريال اكبر جراح في مصر
العالمي شنوده الذي عثر عليه عام 2018 في
احدى الكنائس تبنته السيده امال وزوجها
وبعد اربع سنوات تقدمت احدى قريبات الوالد
بسبب خلافات حول الميراث ببلاغ كيدي بان
الطفل مختطف ولم يعثر عليه في الكنيسه
الامر الذي ادى الى ايداعه من ذ عام في
احدى دور الرعايه ودخول الاسره في اجراءات
قانونيه وقضائيه انتهت بصدور فتاوى من
الازهر ودار الافتاء بان الطفل يتبع ديانه
الاسره المسيحيه التي وجدته في الكنيسه
وصدور قرار من النيابه بتسليم الطفل
لاسرته بالتبني الطفل ده عدل تشريعات لم
تستطع مؤسسات كبيره في مصر ان تعدلها هذا
الطفل لم تكن قانون الاسره بديله يطبق على
المسيحيين كلمه اسره مؤقته اثار
لان
المفروض اني ان الاسره تنهي اجراءات
الاسره البديله كل هذه الامور قد تستغرق
شهر او شهرين فكانت النيابه العظيمه
المحترمه النيابه العامه يعني لديها من حس
الانساني والحس القانوني وبعد الانساني
قالت لا يعني احنا دلوقتي يقعدوا شهر على
الطفل بعيد عن ابوه وامه والقرار صدر
فاحنا هندي مصطفى مؤقته وهي بعد كده تجيب
الحاجات دي كلها وبحسب القانون فان قرار
النيابه اسدل الستار على ماساه طفل لم
يتعدى الخمس سنوات ليعود الى حضن الام
والاب بالتبني والذي لم يعرف غيرهما راندا
ابو العزم العربيه القاهره
كان وزير الهجره البريطانيه ان بلاده اعدت
خطه جديده لاواء المهاجرين الذين يصلون
الى بريطانيا عبر قوارب صغيره من فرنسا
وقال ان الحكومه ستاوي الالاف في مراكز
ايواء عسكريه مؤكدا ان اواء المهاجرين
يكلف الحكومه 6 ملايين الف جنيه استرليني
يوميا
في ختام التاسعه مشاهدينا تذكير بابرز
العناوين
تقرير صادم يكشف عدد الرؤوس النوويه
الجاهزه للاستخدام في العالم اكثر من 9000
بعد تصعيد
التصرياهو الاخير يحذر الوزراء ويشدد على
العلاقه مع واشنطن
بايدن يعترف باستمرار ازمه البنوك في
الولايات المتحده وانخفاض شعبيته الى ادنى
مستوياتها
الموظفون الحكوميون في الولايات المتحده
يودعون تيك توك بعد انتهاء مهله الحكومه
لحذف التطبيق
مشاهدينا الى هنا اتي الى ختام التاسعه
لكن طبعا اخبار العربيه مستمره كما كل
ليله والان الى 360 والزميله راويه راويه
ماذا لديك الليله مساء الخير اهلا بك ليال
سنتحدث عن الهجوم المضاد هجوم الربيع الذي
تنوي اوكرانيا القيام به وفرص نجاحه
بالاضافه طبعا الى التوتر في العلاقات بين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه واسرائيل